Thank you. Uh, hi everyone. This is
going to be a bit of whiplash moving
from hardware hacking to whatever I'm
about to talk about, but stick with me.
We'll get there. Um, I'm Rammy. I'm a
security researcher at Whiz. And this
talk is about the series of supply chain
attacks that have been crossing npm and
GitHub in the past year. But it's not
really about that. It's about how AI has
developed in the past year. How models
have improved, how harnesses have
improved, and how your practices should
have improved as well. And it's not
really that as well. It's just basically
me showing a bunch of things I've done
with AI around these attacks and talking
about what I've learned, the intuition
I've built about how to use AI, where it
fails, where it succeeds, and hopefully
you can take away uh something to do
with it as well. So with that being
said, um the past year is something I've
been talking about as the year of the
worm. There were series of supply chain
attacks, right? Uh Singularity, Shy
Halude, the npm chalk attack uh hitting
mostly the npm ecosystem and in many
cases starting in August resulting in
large amounts of data leaking out onto
GitHub uh with Singularity. And our
problem here, right, is that we need to
capture this data, analyze it, and
figure out who it belongs to so that we
can notify victims so that companies can
respond and recover. However, uh the
data is ephemeral. GitHub cleans it up,
victims clean it up. Uh the data is
going to go away and once it's gone, it
becomes very hard to answer those
questions of was I impacted. And these
challenges are AI shaped, right?
Scaling, collection, analyzing the data
at high speed, doing victim attribution.
And I'm going to talk about all the ways
that that's true. So like goal one is
how do we get this data? Um like the
data is still leaking. I know it's going
to be ephemeral. I want to move quickly
and collect as much data as I can. Not
because I enjoy having gigabytes of
secrets on my disc, but because I want
to help people. And like just to flash
up what it looked like in the
Singularity attack, um what we had was
these GitHub repositories called
Singularity repository. Uh that's a
encoded data, but you just have to
believe me that there's a whole bunch of
secrets in there. Um and so what do we
do? Right. This isn't a data scraping
talk, so I'm just going to give you the
naive example. Uh, you go to Claude. Um,
and I recreated this last week. I
originally did this in August just so
that folks couldn't tell me it was using
an old model or an old coding harness,
right? And you say, "Hey, you know, use
the GitHub Cly to grab all of these
repositories by name." And what's
interesting when you do this is it
totally works, right? It's still magic
that AI generates code that works at
all. But there's a whole bunch of things
missing when you ask such a simple
stupid question. You're missing
non-functional and functional
requirements. You're missing things like
caching, like it impotency, like
handling of search rate limiting, um
creative approaches to scraping,
parallelization,
backoffs. There are all these things
that AI does not solve for you or give
you unless you are using it right. And
so like one is you can't just assume you
can give a dumb prompt and AI will pop
out magic. you have to be thoughtful.
Um, but you also can build harnesses and
processes and approaches that bake this
in. So, one thing to think about is the
idea of an RPI loop. Um, you should be
asking AI to research, asking AI to plan
and then finally going to
implementation. Don't just jump to uh,
you know, please write this script. Um,
this is also something that can be
encoded in the tools. Claude has plan
mode. Plan mode is like a couple lines
of prompt that says stop and plan and
don't write any code yet. Um, you can
also build your own harnesses or adopt
alternative ones, whatever platform
you're in. Going a bit further, there's
a repository called superpowers that
tries to encode a seven-step process for
developing code. And this talk is not
telling you like go pull down
superpowers and and start using it to
solve all your problems. But I really
want to emphasize that you need to be
thinking about how you are engaging with
these tools because the magic of code
generation is one thing, but actually
using them in practice is another. Um,
and so superpowers gives you a
brainstorming as stage one, which is
again very similar to that RPI loop. Um,
and there's another thing about like
working in rapid iteration with these AI
tools. Uh, this is something I stole
from Simon. I think he wrote it like 3
days ago, so it's pretty fresh, but he
wrote it called hoarde things you know
how to do. And I think about it as
building composable utilities. As you're
vibe coding, as you're working with AI,
people are telling you code is free.
People are telling you you can throw
away code. I somewhat agree, but it took
you effort to get there. The effort's
going to get lower and lower over time,
but as you build some of these
utilities, you're going to find yourself
wanting to reach back for them. And the
vibe coding patterns, for me at least,
result in a whole bunch of data strewn
around my disc that I don't know how to
reference in the future. Um, so thinking
about how you're going to do management
of all these small utilities, skills,
the things you're building so that your
investment can compound is really
important.
So, we scrape the data and what do we
end up with? Well, like poor man's data
lake, right? Um, a quarter of a million
flat files, 30 gigabytes, by no means
big data. Um, you know, you can work
with it on your laptop. Uh, but enough
data that linear scanning gets IO bound.
I I like talk about the shape of the
data here because what's interesting is
despite um, you know, several iterations
of working with data of this shape with
AI, I noticed that AI is actually never
going to question the abstraction you
give it. So when you give it flat files
on disk, that is what AI assumes to work
with. And you're not going to get to
that point where it's questioning
whether this should be indexed, whether
this should be SQL parquet, right? Um so
again, a thing you have to pull back and
plan for. Uh and fundamentally the idea
that like flat files are the final
abstraction of AI, I think is is untrue.
Um, and there's been some recent
analysis from Verscell and Brain Trust,
for example, that that talks about this
idea that there are things that AI is
good with bash and flat files. And there
are times when you want to start to move
into um, you know, more indexed database
querying patterns. Uh, okay, we have a
whole bunch of data. What is the shape
of the data? How do we analyze it? How
do we understand what happened here? Um,
and what's going on? So, the first thing
that was a really cool oneshot from AI
was the concept of fingerprinting. So we
had 30,000 leaked repositories full of
data from various machines, right? So it
would be environment files, the results
of truffle hog scans, a whole lot of
data. Um, but in looking at the data,
you could see things like CI/CD runs
having duplicate data. So it wasn't
actually 30,000 victims. Um, and being
able to use Claude to derive signals is
a huge part of it. being able to use
these AI tools. And so being able to
like oneshot a fingerprint that would
let me dduplicate machines uh lets you
think more critically about the
underlying data. And so when you're
analyzing data with AI, I would say
think about dduplication,
fingerprinting, but especially um AI is
really good at signal extraction,
pattern matching, identifying the shape
of the data, and that ports as well to
identifying like useful metadata. So we
were looking at this data. It's uh you
know malware had run on machines and
leaked data. Were those machines user
laptops or were they CI/CD systems? Were
those systems containerized? What sort
of programming languages were running?
What sort of packaging ecosystems? Could
we analyze the packages that had been
the initial root cause of this incident?
Um, and again, the ability to jump from
a human trying to identify these
patterns to Claude kicking out um, you
know, 25 different environment variables
that signify various CI/CD platforms
I've never heard of is a big level up.
But like I've been talking about
patterns AI can recognize, but I also
want to talk about approach um, and
really advocate for this idea of
feedback loops and codification. So when
you're working with AI for data
analysis, when you're building an AI
process, I always try and get to more
deterministic methods where possible,
right? So like we're trying to analyze
this data. Instead of asking an AI to
iteratively analyze 30 GB, you want to
use the AI to generate a more
deterministic script, um to encode some
patterns, some signatures for
scalability, consistency, iteration,
back testing. If you're asking AI to
analyze the data over and over again,
you're going to get different small
samples. Um, and so instead, you can
distill the learnings and codify them
into something more deterministic. And
so in this case, we found out from that
fingerprinting, there were 13,000 unique
machines, not 30. Um, 77% of CI/CD
runners.
Okay, so we know the shape of the data.
We've started to look at it. Um, the big
question here really and like where I
really had to lean on AI was trying to
attribute it. I have 13,000
repositories. Um, how do I find out who
the heck's data this is and maybe give
it back to them?
And uh, like in increasing order of
sophistication,
I would start from this idea of uh, like
the magic of reasoning models, something
we're all familiar with. Um, this is me
being abusive towards Gemini. I took uh,
every GitHub repository name from this
data set. I forgot to add new lines, so
they were all merged into a single
string. I fed them into Gemini and I
provided garbage and got back gold.
Right? You're able to ask questions
like, "Find me the 10 major companies."
Now, you can't ask, "Find me every
company, but you can start to take
samples at very high signal. Reasoning
models have really changed this game."
Um, for like processing bulkaned data.
Um, and you also need to think about the
approximate knowledge of many things
present in AI. like it's not just the
fact that it can analyze this data, but
it's the fact that so much knowledge is
encoded that you can start doing
different pattern matching, right? So,
it knows what uh companies or or domains
are associated with government entities.
Um, and it was even familiar with things
like the Fortune 100 or you could do the
AI top 50 or you could ask about the top
VC fundraises of the last year, right?
There's all sorts of ways to slice this
data with reasoning models. And the
upside is creativity. Um, one of the
things that surprised me and and maybe I
was naive, but uh, you know, claude
analyzing this data, uh, anthropic
models, uh, other models, right, can
identify that an encoded JWT is likely
to contain claims that had signal worth
extracting, right? Looking at an encoded
string as an LLM and pulling out that
sort of signal was surprising and
creative and something maybe I wouldn't
have thought of. But the downside is
credul, especially for security use
cases. the culity the gullibility of
LLMs becomes really dangerous. So these
were cases where like the string nucleus
appeared in some data and somehow it
connected it to a specific company that
uses a platform named Nucleus which is I
think an incredibly common name for
platforms. Um anyone using uh you know
Azure DevOps must mean they work at
Microsoft and are a a Microsoft uh
victim. Um and similarly like finding
JWTs that have login to consumer
Microsoft services and attributing that
uh so the double-edged sword here
creativity and credul
there's also a challenge with um like
exploring the entire coverage coverage
is really hard when you're building some
of these systems and it's all about the
harnesses not the models I think um AI
will almost always take a shortcut and a
sample if you ask AI to analyze all of
something write me every rule rule,
cover all of this data, give me every
company, you're going to get back, you
know, oh, I decided to to pick the top
10 for you. Aren't I so helpful? Um,
this is where like Ralph loops come in,
something very trendy recently, but this
idea that you just like keep an
automated harness that reprompts it to
keep going, keep going, keep going until
it hits exit criteria. And that's a
simple wow loop. The idea is sound that
you need to be thinking about how you're
harnessing these models into your
processes and what the behaviors you
want are. If you want coverage, you have
to know that that's not something you
get by default.
Okay, pivoting a little on examples.
Another place that uh we thought of to
mine signal was enriching secrets.
Right? There are a bunch of secrets in
this data. If we enrich and validate the
secrets, we can find potentially the
user it belongs to or the company and
use that information as attribution
signal. There are a lot of secrets
tools. Um I've frequently used truffle
hog in the past. It's a been a very
popular tool for a long time partially
because it has a really robust library
of detectors. It has almost 800
detectors I think. Uh and for a long
time in security picking a tool was
about picking your rule set, right? like
you would pick up bandit or something
because you knew it had the best rules
for for that SAS language and that's not
true anymore. So in this case uh truffle
hog had characteristics that were
undesirable. It's uh commonly
fingerprinted and causes alerts which
can cause noise for teams. Validation
has a high rate of false negatives I'd
seen in past research. It's relatively
slow. And so you know 253 I'd just say
hey go find all of the rules here that
are are trivial rules that have secrets
that have prefixes. it's a get request
or a post request to validate the
secret. It's really easy for an LLM to
port that over and uh 30 minutes later I
have 58 new rules in a totally different
engine. And it's less so about like what
secret scanning tool you should be
using. Uh and it's very much about this
idea that product content rules uh
detectors are becoming fungeible and the
engines are really what's starting to
matter because you can start porting
around content and you should be
thinking about the engine
characteristics. Do you want something
that's fast? Do you want something that
has a low rate of uh false positives or
a low rate of false negatives? What are
you optimizing for? And pick your engine
and just assume you can move the rules
around between tools. Uh whether that's
in open- source or um you know maybe
porting something like sigma rules to a
proprietary platform, right? I think
rules are becoming much more funible.
So when I talked about the victimology,
I talked a little bit about codifying
things in scripts and moving towards
determinism. I also have been talking a
lot with folks about this idea of
feedback loops with how we use AI. Um AI
is a tool that's part of a toolkit. And
so I really like to think about it as
how it fits in the overall ecosystem.
And so what that process looks like here
was taking AI based analysis samples and
running it through an attribution scale
and then taking that result, that new
signal, and identifying new
deterministic rules we could add that we
could then run and see the uplift. Did
this increase our coverage? And so
here's an example where it identified a
a new variable that hosted what appeared
to be self-hosted Git instances. Um, and
then after we ran this, we found, you
know, a major Russian e-commerce company
that I've failed to censor there because
I don't really want to. Uh, but also
like a Portuguese company, a Thai
fintech, a US fortune 500. And this is
just one signal. And so this pattern of
taking samples, but then having the
feedback loop into uh, you know, more
concrete rules then improves your
ability on future scans to sort of
repeat the cycle. And I think this is
true outside of this like data analysis
space. If you're building detections,
right? If you're building um
configuration rules, I think the same
loop of using AI but trying to use AI to
get to determinism really applies. Um
use AI for the things that it's uniquely
good at. Uh don't necessarily like rip
and replace all your deterministic
methods.
So the end result here was like a aentic
analysis tool. Um this was something
where I had 69 different attribution
methods that had been built um mostly by
AI at this point. Uh and so you would
like extract a bunch of signals, take
those signals and use them to guess at
the company um and then do some
enrichment from secrets enrichment,
GitHub API lookups, etc. And so like
just as an example here, right, like we
have everything from GitHub enterprise
instances to orgs to extracting things
from JWTs. Um again, this isn't about
how to do attribution necessarily. So
going through all 69 isn't interesting,
but it's worth pointing out that there's
a long tale here, which is where that AI
loop comes into play.
So credul was something I mentioned
earlier. Uh, and I want to talk about
like the most basic counterpoint to
cruel you can do is to inject
skepticism. So in a naive way, injecting
skepticism into the system is just
stopping yourself in a, you know, in a
chat session with a coding agent and
saying, "Hey, let's slow down. Let's
check if these are true positives,
right?" Creating an attribution skill,
running it through. Um, there's also way
more sophisticated harness-based
approaches you can take. You could
actually write a skeptical persona and
run, you know, a mix of agents who are
sort of balancing each other out. Um,
but fundamentally I think that you need
to inject skepticism when doing these
cases because the baseline alignment
feels a little credulous for a lot of
security purposes.
Human in the loop. So we talked a lot
about how to do these feedback loops
with AI, right? Like AI for analysis,
distilled deterministic rules, but at
some point I also was seeing that there
were just patterns I could identify that
AI wasn't pulling out, right? Like there
were short terms that I knew that AI
wasn't identifying. Um, and what's
really cool here actually is the new
concept of just in time programs. So
when you're working with AI for
analysis, what's really cool is that
instead of like manually looking at
data, it's almost always more efficient
these days to just prompt up a throwaway
tool, right? Like you can just create a
tool here in this case that let me skim
the data uh identify the attributes that
I thought had signal and then feed those
to the LM to do iterative cycles. And so
being able to build these throwaway
tools is something you should be
reaching for all the time. It's one of
those things in your tool belt that once
you know it exists, all of a sudden you
find uh a lot of hammer-shaped nails or
what have you.
And like this was the case here where um
I noticed that there were Azure DevOps
or slugs. Um and I happened to know that
you can actually transit from those
through to tenant ids through into
actual domains through like some poorly
documented APIs. Something I'd been
looking at recently. This was something
AI didn't pull out. Like props to me.
Pat myself on the back. Um but then you
just feed it to an LM and all of a
sudden you have a six-stage enrichment
as one of the 69 different enrichments
in this engine, right? um you know
transiting through oi uh open ID lookups
through API calls and then actually
distilling what the most likely match
is.
So what did this all get me? Well um the
headline number I've been using is that
the Shylude 2.0 incident concretely
impacted at least 37 of the Fortune 100.
I have manually confirmed all of those
cases. I'm not relying on LM to tell me
that. um 37 of the Fortune 100 had some
level of impact from this incident. But
more importantly uh the agentic analysis
found over 2400 impacted companies and
this was after sort of two days of
building this engine heavily leveraging
AI. Uh the two weeks prior I had done a
lot of this manually um and I had found
200 impacted companies. Uh and so an
idea of scale. Now this doesn't solve
all your problems but uh it you know
really goes to show the argument for
relative investment to relative output
and we will see. Oh no.
Okay.
Okay. Okay. So quick demo here and
something to take away. Um this is not
the point of the talk but I figured why
not. Uh here's an example of an
attribution skill that encodes a lot of
the generalist knowledge that was
relevant. not this specific instance
like uh 69 attribution methods but just
this idea of given a directory full of
data whose is it um and so I'm running
here just the attribution skill against
a uh a random repository and apologies
if it's a little blurry um you never
know but what is going to be sort of
evident in 3 seconds or so um is that it
will kick out the actual victim here um
and what is going to be really
interesting is this victim was the
Alibaba example but it actually
identified inside the truffle secrets
that one of the secrets was sourced from
a uh dot file that is used by an
internal developer tool for Alibaba AI.
Um so this like these connections that
it's making are something that you can't
necessarily do yourself. And the second
skill here is a security contact skill.
How do you know who to tell about these
2000 instance? Well, you can Google like
company name bug bounty company name
security.ext company name how do I
report a security issue? Company name.
Um, it takes a minute to run a skill
here, but the skill will check all of
those things for you in parallel. Um,
and for Alibaba will end up kicking out
their bug bounty and VW uh, VDP. So,
this was something where I constantly
find myself just like hoping that the
first Google result is correct,
otherwise it turns into 30 minutes of
stalking people on LinkedIn. Um, and so
I wanted to save some peel some time.
So, that is what I will leave you with.
There's a repository there that has
those two skills. take them uh you know,
use them, mix them up. Um and that's
what I got.
It's like a many like a fractal set of
tools in there. I'm excited to put this
to use. Questions? Questions for Army?
Must do. Oh, okay. All the way back
there. Oh, that's inconvenient. All
right. Uh, while we're going and setting
up for Daniel's talk, um, yeah, I'll go
where where's the hand? I lost the hand.
Thank you.
>> Awesome. Thank you. Uh, really
appreciate the talk, Ramy. Uh, one of
the things that you mentioned though was
the value of these ephemeral tools that
you're creating on the fly. I'm curious
if you see like any tension there and
how you may handle it as far as
maintaining the reusability of those
tools. not reinventing the wheel, so to
speak.
>> Yeah, it's a great question. I mean, to
quote uh the wonderful folks at OpenAI
from this morning, code is free. Um, I'm
not too worried about throwing away code
these days because I can do the work to
get it back. I think you should think
about your stakeholders and purpose,
right? If you are building a tool for
your team to use in a weekly process,
put a little more thought into it. But
this is really about the fact that you
can now trivially put an a guey on any
process you're about to do. If you're
about to sit down and do something for
an hour, think about whether 10 minutes
of that would be better served by making
a clean UX that isn't necessarily a
terminal.
Anything else?
>> Uh because a lot of people are asking AI
question uh excuse me, cost of AI
questions like any sense of what the
token burn is for this? Is it sort of
one time or do you find it negligible?
>> Yeah. Um, I find it negligible because
I'm not paying to be honest. But, uh, I
think something like this on the order
of 80 bucks. Um, I think is where it
works out to. And again, that's cuz I'm
not feeding 30 GB to the context window
every time. Uh, that is where using some
of these deterministic methods can
shortcut some of the uh, you know, token
usage. Um, especially when you're taking
samples and that would scale up linearly
if you were taking more samples and sort
of repeating add infinium.
>> Cool. Awesome. Thank you very much.
>> Yeah. Thank you.